அப்படியே எழுத்துண்டா, அந்தக் கஷ்டம் பெரிச்சா இருக்கும். நான் அதை பெரிச்சா கழுத்தில் எழுத்துக்கொள்ளவிருக்கிறான்.
அப்போது அது எனக்கு தண்டனை இல்லை. வெளியே இருந்து பார்க்கும் ஆளுக்கு வேண்டும் என்றால் அது கஷ்டமா இருக்கலாம்.
நோயாடி வந்து, அம்மா வந்துவிட்டது, அது சரி, கட்டம் பா, அது ஏதாவது வந்திருக்கிறது.
காமாட்டுக்கு என்னுடைய முக்கு எழுதுவது வேலையை, இதைப் பண்ணுவேன் அப்படி நிறுக்கிறான்,
பக்கத்தில் இருக்கும் அவன் என்ன சொல்லலான், நீங்கள் எப்படி தடுமாறுகிறீர்கள்,
எப்படி வலியில் துடிக
எப்படி வழியில் துடிக்கிறீர்கள், மிகவும் கஷ்டம் அப்படின்னு, அவனுக்குக் கஷ்டம் இல்லையே, அவன்தான் தண்டனையா, அனுபவித்தால்தானே தண்டனை, அவன் அனுபவிக்குமே இல்லையே,
மற்ற கைதிகள் புலம்பிக்கொண்டு இருக்கிறான், அழுகிறான், இவரும் அனுத்தமாக கீதை எழுதிக்கொண்டு இருக்கிறார், கீதாராஹச்சியமாக அந்த கர்மகியோகப்பத்தி,
அப்போது அந்த பேஷன்ட், அந்த சப்பரர் கர்மத்துடைய தண்ணையை அனுபவிக்கும்வர்,
அவரும் எதுவும் தண்ணவன்தில் விலக்கிக்க வேண்டும், அது ஒன்றுதான் செல்லும், இது எப்படி முடியும், அதற்கு என்ன பயிற்சி செய்யவேண்டும், அப்படி இருக்கும் என்று அடுத்த கேள்வி வரும், அப்படி போலாம்,
அவர்கள் கேள்விலேயே மூது காலை அச்பெட்டு நாங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கலாம், கேள்வி ரெகாடா இருக்கா, நோட்பிட்டு இருக்கார்கள், செய்யும் ஐயா, நாங்கள் படிவிட்டீர்கள், நீங்கள் கூறிய அச்பெட்டில் நியானா, நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள்,
நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள், நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள், நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள், நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள், நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள், நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள், நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள், நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள்.
நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள், நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள், நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள், நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள்.
நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள், நீங்கள் கேள்வியிருக்கிறீர்கள்.
இதனாலனா நிறைய விஷயங்கள் நம் வாழ்க்கையில் நம் கொண்டில் இல்லை. நம் விஷயங்கள் நடக்கும்போது நாம் இது வந்து இது கர்மா, இது நம்மே ஏற்றுப்போம், இதுயும் கடந்து போகோம் அப்படியென்ற எண்ணங்களை எடுத்துக்கொள்கிறோம்.
அப்படியென்றால் இது வந்து கர்மா என்றது